actions predict future behavior past
actions predict future behavior if a
woman is impaired bonding look it up
she's more likely to revert to being a
304 infidelity divorce and if she isn't
bonded to her mate what sense
what sense man is going to willing to
bet she will is willing to bet that she
will make moral and sound decisions
so it's like she's saying like if you're
sleeping around now like then that like
um i think that's really reductionist um
so if you knew me i was suicidal i tried
to kill myself a couple of times
um and so if you knew me who i was um
even a year ago no not actually not a
year ago year ago was good but two years
ago i was very codependent i was very i
had very low self-worth i had and so to
be like your past actions determine who
you are no you've spoke about
self-awareness it's all about yeah you
can't say if a guy went to prison three
times for for attempted battery he might
do it again oh no 100 i understand like
you you can say that you can't say that
but to reduce a woman to be like oh just
because so i was very codependent and so
the men i date now
would be like well based on your history
you want a relationship with me you're
gonna fall in love with me and i'm like
you are very confused i don't want that
at all right now i will because i'm very
different
i'm so i've been i've been single by
choice for a year and a half like that's
not a bad thing it's okay to like fall
in love it's like a year and a half it's
been a year and a half and i've not yeah
yeah but but i'm i'm saying like
your question if you met a guy that you
really liked and you were considering
him for a relationship
and he told you that he had cheated in
every relationship previous to this
are you saying that would not at all
impact his desirability to you for a
boyfriend no i'm not saying that i'm not
again it's that's it it's not black and
white it's not one-size-fits-all i will
i will keep saying so i'm going i'm blue
in the face it's not one-size-fits-all
not saying not saying that it'd be like
not saying it's the deciding factor but
like would it not shift your opinion of
him potentially as a boyfriend or do you
think if that would not impact your view
of him at all no no being being
realistic yeah
being a realist yeah and the same way so
you'd understand if a guy viewed like
basically sleeping around a lot the same
way but then we've got yeah yeah but
then we've got
um if you ever like 500 days of summer
is one of my favorite films and she says
when you know you know and i've dated a
lot of guys who are like i'm never gonna
be a relationship i'm never gonna i was
like well you will you you will meet
someone at some point in your life it's
probably inevitable
that you will meet someone that you're
like i'm going to settle down i don't
agree with when you know you know i
think that you make a choice
and like that's it like i don't think
most people well yeah when we know that
it's the right choice but i'm saying i
don't think you'll ever know and i think
that's like a lot of like now fear today
and like dating today is people thinking
that they're just gonna they're just
gonna know but all you can do is make a
decision with the information that you
have but then yeah but then you'll know
that like
and even nowadays like people are dating
like what a decade five years three
years before they decide to get married
do you think those people just knew if
they're dating three
like
i don't think they know it's the one i
don't believe in the one but i think
they know that they especially and so it
that research shows that women will kind
of um
look for that long term men will get to
a point where they're suddenly like
oh [ __ ] i kind of need to settle down
now ergo i'm gonna look right if she's
here and she fits in she'll do so men
actually technically end up settling and
they don't know why is that one why is
it settling it's no it's it's they just
made a choice they said okay yeah i'm
looking to like get married in this time
frame this girl fits everything i i i'm
looking for but she doesn't necessarily
fit everything they're looking for
that's why because people aren't perfect
so i don't i don't think it's
really settling if you say okay she
doesn't have everything like it's kind
of like do you know what she'll do yeah
i think women could be better but she'll
do yeah but i think women like
probably could you know have a little
bit more he'll do yeah yeah i don't
think that's a bad thing because i'm not
perfect yeah i can't expect the guy dave
to be perfect
and so like
yeah like i just i don't like the word
settling it's not settling yeah i i like
you agree because especially with like
romance and like novels and like films
and stuff you believe that there's this
idea of the one and i know and it's like
you actually don't you actually just
need to be okay with what is and what's
happening and be like will you want more
probably a lot of people in
relationships and marriages you can ask
someone to be like what do you love
about your partner what do you not love
what do you wish was different like even
i would not date a snorer and that is
and that's uh if you don't have a
driver's license and you snore and
people are like well that's not made
people's fault and i was like i
literally know that i would want to kill
you if both of those things weren't a
thing yeah but if i really loved a guy
then i'd be like well [ __ ] it i don't
care i don't know i say like girls have
all these standards until they met the
guy that makes them not care but then
it's like well do i do i know or am i
like yeah here's i always say i'd be the
type i swear to god i'd get married in
six months because i feel like there's
risk there's risk regardless
i'd rather just do it and hope for the
best and if it doesn't i'll get divor
like but like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go into something
like okay being afraid of divorce
whatever it happens i hope it doesn't
happen to me like do you think you would
be more afraid of divorce if you're a
man
oh yeah i absolutely would yeah
because mine gets screwed over so oh
actually no no i got i got
i'm in this situation i should be afraid
of tomorrow
i should be afraid
you should actually yeah you should but
nah i mean i think like again there's
risk with everything like so you think
if you're if you're a man you would look
at marriage as openly as you do now
um
probably not probably not i have a
question do you think your dad if he was
in our generation would get married
today yes you think he did yeah he he
wants my brother to get married oh wow
no i mean my dad my parents are more
like traditional so oh that's like
like i don't know i think there's a lot
of legal issues and problems that like
i'll advocate for for matt like they're
not represented fairly in court like i
don't i don't think that you should be
able to take half a man's income just
because you had a kid together yeah i
think i'll be i think the laws are only
going to change
in
not the next generation next generation
after because a lot of men are saying
they're not going to get married because
of it and i think because women still
want to get married they're going to
start advocating for those laws to
change yeah no probably i think that's
probably what you're going to say just
quickly
piggybacking off of that i think a lot
of like yeah you're saying men don't
want to get married women do and there's
a lot there's there is a lot of
dependency upon like taking a man's name
and like getting a mortgage all that
stuff but i really want to know how do
you feel about like
dad's giving their daughter away
oh i think it's a really cute tradition
i wish i would i tell my dad i was i
tell him he could pick out my husband
all the time he doesn't want to though
he says i've got i'm busy
oh okay
oh
so for me it'd be nice if he's like no
i'm not going to pick your husband you
pick someone that you think is well
that's kind of what he does he's like
because if it goes wrong you'll blame me
he's like i'm not being in charge of
that i have to meet your dad at some
point if he's ever in london you have to
tell me oh no
and you know i know from that's it my
own bias and my like poor relation with
my dad i'm like i hate the idea of
belonging to a man and being given to a
man but i know that actually if i had a
good relationship with my dad i'd
probably be in your shoes i'd probably
yeah it's actually really sweet i mean
because you're i think like as women i
mean
we're attracted to shitty traits and we
can't really help it like i'm
freud we have a field day no like we
like [ __ ] we do i mean and i
understand like the science of why it's
like the dark triad trait it's like the
same trait yeah can you can you define
the dart track because only discovered
this recently oh god i don't remember it
off the top of my head but it's like
like a guy that's aggressive right like
why do women stay with the men that like
beat them because the same men that like
are aggressive and like beat them can
also beat up someone else so it's the
same trait right a guy
like a guy that's controlling right he
also can control the environment yep
yeah so it's i don't remember all of
them but it's like it's like the same
traits that make a guy like completely
like an awful like partner also make him
a really good one yeah so i i have a
question for the ladies on the panel um
if you know that this is what you're
attracted to why do you think so many
women say they just want a nice guy
i don't think they realize that things
so do you yeah i was gonna so my next
question was do you think a lot of women
are unaware of what they're actually
attracted to yes
yes
i really think it comes from
inexperience because at the end of the
day being nice is not enough it's really
not enough it's the bare minimum it's
like breathing it's like i don't think
being nice is actually
admired to be honest like a bit like
condition like unconditional kindness
from a man i think is seen as weakness
because well it's because like it's a
guy that doesn't like because a lot of
times this is this is my experience a
lot of times guys will say they're nice
but they're not they're not actually
nice
they're not nice they're afraid to stand
up for themselves and they're they like
we don't like guys that put us on a
pedestal like why do we think we like
like guys that make fun of us a little
bit yeah because you're treating us like
we're human so if we say something dumb
and you call it like
yeah or they think they're nice because
they're like well i'm not raping someone
i'm not beating you up ergo i'm nice and
i'm like
i've never heard a guy say that
we've never heard a guy say that
a personal experience but yeah no i
think everyone guys say they're nice
they're like i've given her everything i
take her here i do this i do this i
think it's a lot of guys that go above
and beyond for women but women don't
respect guys that give them everything
without making them earn it but then we
get in cell culture and so it's like men
who are like i'm xyz it's like you're
not though you're not as good as you
think you are you are the best being
nice is the better well i think incels
are kind of a result of women not
settling
and like like women saying i'd rather be
alone than have to settle instead of
like i don't know and then this goes
back to i actually think men are not i
actually think
i actually think as much as i'm for
female empowerment and like i actually
think men end up settling more
and i think men actually end up
disappointing themselves more being like
if you asked a man write down your
perfect woman on paper and let's compare
it to the woman that you ended up with
i think that yeah i think a lot more
women are actually like i'd rather be
alone than settle but then it's like you
actually could be alone forever if
you're not willing to settle if you're
not
but you can but you can't you can but
then you'll be homeless yeah yeah most
women you need 2.5 million to retire
um